here's patrick corbin
he knows the rockies and they know him
23rd career start and garrett hampson
ready to go
and he'll swing and drive a ball to
center field going back thomas still
going back off the top of the wall
thomas retrieves it hamson pulls into
second with a double number two hitter
is brendan rodgers and here's one of the
stars from last night and this ball's
well hit right center field by brennan
rogers and this is god
two run oppo shot two nothing colorado
good afternoon patrick corbin
pitches in
the rockies are off to a flying starch
200 is hit hard to center field thomas
going back it's over his head it'll one
hop the wall krone on his way to third
diaz into second with a double
and the banner will be ryan mcmahon
this ball down
the third base line it goes off of key
boom one run is scored
and it's three nothing colorado number
21 kyle freeland making his 21st start
of the year
as a sign from diaz is 2-2 backdoor
breaking balls strike three called
here's the 2-2
and he got him whoa look at a hard
cutter
this ball is down the first base line
past zimmerman soto trying to hold
rogers to a single he will not be able
to do that home run and a double for
brendan so far in the ball game
that one to the left of escobar hit hard
and that's it
but the bases are loaded for alex avila
and this ball grounded to first there's
one and on the first
in time kyle kind of got run over
and uh i think he's fine yep
thomas hitting it 247 five dingers 23
rbis
had a streak of 15 straight games
reaching base he swings and grounds it
to rogers near second flips to story for
one on to first for the double play
four to six to three
and he'll get him looking again for
strikeout number five
trevor story
oh for two
now he's got that sign from avila
3-1 pitch swung on and hit in the air to
right field soto giving ground and he's
going to watch it go
over and out of here for trevor story
the other way
three run homer
and the rockies build on their lead
six to nothing
walked three times last night had a base
hit
that is a rocket to left field
and it'll check up at the 336 mark
soto hustling in the second
and you know what we're going to do as
soon as it comes up we're going to give
you his updated batting average
314 into that ap
and reinhardt still throwing it appears
she's
gonna be in in the fifth inning
soft tapper freeland covers
crone gave him the ball and plenty of
time to find the bag of the nets waste
the lead off double by one
soda hitting 3
16.
swinging a miss on that hook
and kyle freeland continues to throw
nasty curve balls to right-handed
batters
now this one might be the nastiest too
look at this
back door
swung on and missed freelance strikes
out of vela and that is 500 punch-outs
in kyle's career
the average for him the strikeouts have
grown as the year has gone on oh two
breaking balls swaying and a miss
freeland strikes out the side
we head to the sixth
six nothing rockies
who struck out six and not walked
anybody six nothing rocky's lead
freely into the line the pitch to thomas
lined up the middle a base into center
field
well he didn't get escobar on that
breaking ball away that time
two on nobody out
table set for juan soto
soto turns on one speared by crone
and off the bag at second everybody is
safe
well if you came to the ball game today
[Applause]
this is what you came for to see ryan
zimmerman hit with the bases loaded
1-1 pitch bouncing ball to freeland to
the plate for one to first for a double
play
[Applause]
third double play of the afternoon and
you get that lead runner at the plate
thomas has faced almonte once over one
with a line out three balls and two
strikes pitched to thomas swing and a
miss
got him on a breaking ball now it's up
to escobar
and that thing was a big sweeping slider
case of thomas and escobar and one
subtle have to wait till the eighth
nets can't break through
shutout through seventh
so here's another chance
for brendan rodgers sitting on a homer
double single day
off speed escobar fantastic play for the
force at second
6-4 on a dazzler
[Applause]
three men to the right side for juan
soto
juan soto walks for the
124th time this year
fourth time in the series first today
so now the batter's carter ki boom
two and two
and this one is short there's one and
there's two rockies turn over another
double play their third of the ball game
alex sevilla
0-4-2 career against daniel barge
and this is popped up
rogers will be allowed to take this one
cj says you can grab it and that is the
rocky's sixth shutout of the year
they beat washington six to nothing on a
saturday late afternoon in d.c